let me let us uh introduce our next
speaker Ryan curtain he earned his PhD
studying acceleration of statistical
algorithms at Georgia Tech in in 2015
and he is the maintainer of ml Pac which
is implemented in C++ for machine
learning and he'll go over his talk
lightweight low overhead High
Performance Machine learning directly in
C++ okay hi yeah so that is what I'm
going to be talking about today
lightweight and high performance and now
I recognize that this conference is
called high data uh but I'll be talking
about C++ so hopefully that's okay but
it's in the title so nothing I've said
so far hopefully is a surprise to you um
so I always like it when people tell me
about where they're from I'm a
geographically oriented person so I'll
do the same uh I am from the great city
of Atlanta it is the best city in the
South um and Atlanta fun fact has the
busiest airport in the world um but the
city is more than just an airport even
though the airport is like a city in the
itself um there's more to do there and
and um I'm in New York City I know that
but I'm going to say that Atlanta is
extremely good Food City so if you need
a food vacation um go fly to the busiest
airport in the world and check it out um
so non-geographically by origin which is
actually relative to this talk uh is I
went to Georgia Tex as of planta right I
kind of got stuck there um but I worked
for a lab at Georgia Tech studying
accelerated machine learning alomes and
so the the goal was you know um how can
you train this model or compute this
result uh in less time using either
better algorithms better implementations
or approximations things along these
lines and everything that we did uh we
implemented in C++ and so this was like
2008 or so and so that was a pretty
common thing you you're doing number
hunching you need to get good results uh
you implemented in C++ because it's fast
um why would you pick another language
why would you pick a Python language in
which four Loops are slow uh so it came
as was a little bit of surprise to me
over the next uh handful of years uh as
python Rose to dominance um as a
language for scientific Computing um and
maybe it didn't take other people by
surprise took me by surprise uh because
again I was saying like why would you do
all of your stuff in this language that
wasn't built for numerical computation
uh and the answer is developer
convenience um the ability to prototype
fast which is extremely important in
data science um yeah that's important
and you really get a lot out of it um
and so hence uh you know everybody uses
python they use use Jew things like this
um but and this is this is the thing
that continues to surprise me and this
is the motivation for this talk um when
you say okay I'm done prototyping uh
it's time to move to production or
whatever you take your python code and
you throw it over the wall at your your
ml Engineers or whatever um now all of
those development conveniences are a
millstone around your neck it is
something that is FL um so uh you know
let's pull out a funny image here
although this image to me actually is
not so much funny as stressful um in my
experience this is kind of what a
typical machine learning deployment that
I have seen kind of looks like uh and
the words that I want to come into your
head are over complicated um over
complex uh bloat um and maybe also a lot
of what even is that anyway um I I don't
know a lot of people uh so as as an
example and let's put a little number
behind that let's say you go take
yourself a miniconda Docker container
and you go install psychic in it um or
you take a tensorflow container uh how
many uh packages are installed something
like 60 um
and I guess if you're a JavaScript
developer you like 60 call me a it's a
million they don't care but I'm a C++
developer and I care a lot about stuff
like that and you should too 60 is a lot
especially if you're saying um we want
to deploy our machine learning model to
something where we have constraints uh
if you have satellites bandwidth is very
expensive size is very expensive you
have a power budget it's not something
that can Flex um if you are uh you know
flying drones around they're not very
powerful devices you want to make sure
whatever machine Lear and model you're
deploying there um can actually fit uh
if you have an iot smart shoe which is
actually a thing that actually seriously
exists I don't know why um but it's got
processing power in it and it probably
has a computational budget too um I
don't want one uh
so I guess let's take a step back what
really is machine learning what do you
need um machine learning is just a
series of linear algebra operations or
other mathematical operations now that's
that's not all there is to it of course
in any real world situation you're going
to say well the data we got it's not
numbers we get something and we need to
turn it into numbers and we're going to
do the number crunching and at the end
of that you have to get the output in
the right format like maybe you need to
uh return some kind of Jason payload or
maybe you need to change the color of a
light or something like that so you got
to get the output in the right format um
importantly that middle number crunching
part that linear algebra is all done at
forr or C or C++ the word typically
there kind of underplay it um everything
uses Bloss or lay pack or open Bloss or
Intel mkl or something that is
implemented in Fortran or C or C++ and
if you say well okay but what about Cuda
k is a C library right it gets wrapped
by other libraries it's all this at the
end of the day um and that's kind of it
like it's if you squint to your machine
learning deployment enough it fits and
if you're like Ryan you forgot a piece
okay we'll add a fourth step right um
this is the guts of it are really that
step two there and that's always going
to be done in some lower level language
so um I want to characteriz or quantify
this question of how much do you really
need uh and so let's start with uh hello
world and I get that's not machine line
but I'll get there uh so our our last
presenter actually didn't really like
the r syntax but um unfortunately here
I'm not I agree I don't like R syntax
but this hello world program is not not
very ugly for R is actually kind of nice
so I don't need to go through the code
here we' probably all seen something
like this but what I do want to do is I
am going to take all of those hello
worlds in each language and I'm going to
put it in a Docker container uh and I'm
just going to measure the size of the do
this is like an okay measurement of how
much do you need um so uh R in Scala you
need to have an entire runtime
environment there they're pretty big um
Julie and python actually ship with
alpine images uh which are meant to be
smaller so I can pack uh my hello world
and python into an Alpine image uh and
that gets it down from you know what
over a gig down to 50 megabytes so
that's good that's good um but if I do
that with C++ uh and I just throw it
into an Alpine container um my starting
point point is like 7.7 migs uh and then
if I then say I'm going to use one of
these newer dist list containers and I'm
going to statically link my hello world
I can get that down to three um I will
also say it's a little bit insane that 3
megabytes is required to print hello
world on the screen I didn't try very
hard here right like this is this is a
starting point you can make Hello World
way smaller than this but again what I'm
trying to characterize is like in a
typical deployment if you say I'm going
to be using python or I'm going to be
using Julia how much do you really need
the reason Reon that it's so much larger
for those other languages is they all
ship with runtime environments whereas
CN C++ things like this they can run
either directly on what the system is
already providing or you can statically
link them and as long as you can run Elf
or something like this boom there you go
so moving on from that example I want to
talk a little bit about the machine
learning stack so your data scientists
are generally going to be working at the
top level of the stack um they'll be
using their own network tool because
like tlow or pytorch or ml pack or pit
um there are tons of those right I can
only you know fit so many logos up there
uh those libraries are all implemented
in terms of higher level linear algebra
libraries so like lpai or armadillo and
C++ uh or bandic Cuda GPU library that I
just developed uh and I have to say it's
extremely cool uh it supports more than
just Nvidia devices and I definitely
don't have a biased perspective at all
uh Julia R in mat lab uh the linear
algebra is actually built into language
um but what all of these have in common
is that you know I kind of referenced
this already they all link against a
Bloss or L pack replacement right that's
what's actually going on over the hood
often these are implemented in Fortran
not always I think open Bloss uses some
C++ uh you've got Intel mkl and you've
got accelerated versions like magma is a
uh joint CPU GPU but it all implements
the same Bloss and lay pack Library
pretty much
asterisk down below that uh and as you
go down uh the logos get worse um uh you
you have your actual compiler right
above the level of the the bare metal
right you have GCC or maybe you have
clang or maybe you a visual studio or
maybe you have does Portland group still
even make compilers even can pay for I I
don't actually know the answer to that
um so why have I put this entire stack
here the reason is that I want to point
out every arrow here is an abstract it's
a layer of abstraction there a whole
pile of layers of abstractions here and
that's important because every
abstraction has a cost sometimes it's
small sometimes it's large but every
abstraction has a cost so when I am at
my top level your your people who are
implementing say d uh they are
expressing their machine learning
algorithms in terms of linear algebra
and they do it well actually I'm I'm an
mlac maintainer when I write code for
mlac I think one of my priorities are
both maintainability and speed and
there's a trade-off there so I'm going
to say well I need this code to be
readable and attainable so I might not
write the crazy stuff let's use the
interface that say armadillo provides or
something like that um and there is a
cost to that uh if you go down a level
into the linear algebra libraries the
numpy implementers the armadillo
implementers uh are all working uh to
figure out how my linear algebra
operation how am I going to express that
in terms of Bloss and layback and
there's a cost there sometimes it can be
like putting round pegs into square
holes um and you had to pay for that uh
you keep on going down there's a cost
for your compiler another cost that's
important is the cost of switching
between languages um there's some amount
of wrangling and overhead associated
with that so all of these things add up
um but when you're under a budget uh
well I'm going to you kind of are forced
to pick C++ right like um none of those
hello worlds that I talked about would
be easy to get onto satellite for
instance so let's go with C++ there's a
lot of good things going about C++ the
first being that we can actually do
these things the second is you know part
of the reason for that is that there's
no runtime other than what the system
already has as long as you're running on
a reasonably modern system um the
interfaces to C and foran are are pretty
light they're kind of like built in um
and then uh this is not the subject of
this talk but through C++ templates you
get uh generic programming and that is
an insanely powerful thing um it's
actually if you buy this book here it's
number 12 in the book um it's not only
subject of of a talk um but it's really
a subject of a conference like CPP con
and you people get together and they do
is talk about the crazy things they did
with temp meta programing it's really
cool um another time uh another thing
you get with c and C++ is uh lowlevel
memory management you got fine grein
control of how you lay your things out
of memory and that's very important for
actually getting speed out of it and
also keeping the size small keeping the
blo small uh as I mentioned re runs on
all reasonable mod modern systems and uh
I mean it's fast and it's small right I
guess I already kind of said that um
there are bad things about C+ plus2 uh
templates can be part of debu if
anybody's ever written template code
yeah so this this image um I like this
image very much uh I didn't make it
myself it is the logo for a competition
and I'm this competition is is actually
called I'm not making this up the grand
C++ error explosion competition um in
which contestants submit short C++
programs with small errors uh and the
the goal the winning entry produces the
most lines of error output based on I
don't know a Dro cic colon or something
like this it's truly insane and I'm not
talking about that you get like you know
100 or a thousand lines of Errors uh
good entries will get 10,000 100,000
into the millions of lines of Errors the
reason being that the compiler says oh
well this is a template so I have to
print the entire
instantiation uh sequence and everything
like this and yeah that makes it hard to
debug it makes it intimidating and it it
really truly does feel like this
sometimes debugging temp so that's that
is a comp um also that memory control is
kind of a double Ed sort it's very easy
to introduce some memory bugs um but
that's a price you pay for control uh
and then uh every couple of years they
introduced a new C++ standard and uh
well the number of pages in The PDF
doesn't get any shorter so I'm not going
to comment on that but I will leave this
image here for just a second or two um
before I move on um so C++ kind of we're
going to be limited to something like
this wants to deploy on low resource
devices uh what is a C++ data science
ecosystem and it's actually quite robust
uh python you know steals all the air
out of room uh for data science but I
mean people need these things so they
also exist on C++ and often python is
wrapping things that are implemented in
C++ anyway um so for linear algebra you
have the armadillo Library the igen
library van Library which I mentioned
there's X tensor there's some efforts to
put uh an object called ND span uh into
the standard temperate Library there's
gml which Powers llama CPP um there are
quite a lot of choices good for
different situations um I will pick
Armadillo in this talk uh because it
gives us good linear algebra Primitives
uh and so what is good linear algebra
primitive uh here's in my example here
we'll create two matrices X and Y
they'll fill them with random numbers
and then we'll say uh The Matrix Z is x
+ y * the cheste decomposition of x + 3
* the cheste decomposition of Y
transpose and why is that a good linear
algebra prenative because the words that
I said looked a lot like the code that
is there so I'll go with this um you
could use other libraries there's
interoperability is easy enough um not
trivial but it can be done so go up a
level uh what do you have for machine
learning in C++ U Pipers and sensor flow
actually C++ apis you could work
directly with those there's ml pack
which I'm maintaining and spond which
sits under it there's D which I
mentioned XG boost has a C++ API there's
darket cat boost llama I already
mentioned that the list goes on and all
on there's also valel wabbit the most
challenging name in all of machine
learning software um so lots of options
here uh I also want to point out
although it's not the subject of the
talk um you actually can use C++
interactively in a notebook um and I've
done this and it's kind of cool and mlac
implements a bunch of examples in it
through the Zeus clean project uh this
is super cool you can use supporting
libraries like xlot or XF frame um and
then of course of C++ it's been around
for years there are support libraries
for kind of whatever you want right oh I
want to load a sound file okay cool you
have a sound file right um so the talk
is about size I'm going to mention speed
uh because speed and size are kind of
correlated um and also because I really
like these benchmarks uh simple in your
outut T so let's just say we want to do
two you got Matrix X and Y two x
transpose plus y + 2 * X Plus y
transpose uh and there's a code to do it
an armadillo um and when you compare
across a bunch of different libraries
like nly from python can new octave the
open source version of mat lab or and
Julia uh what you end up seeing um is
that armadillo is faster why part of it
is the crazy type of meta programming
that I said I wasn't going to talk about
um the other part is is closer to the
system and importantly uh armadillo is
able to do this without creating any
temporary matrices right like ideally
you would do you would compute Z in one
Passover all these things you wouldn't
create a matrix that has 2 * X transpose
plus Y and then add that to something
else right so armadillo gets this right
the others do not um just one more this
is my favorite bench mark um this and
it's my favorite because it's a trick
question let say we have two vectors A B
and C um and what I want to compute is
actually a scalar value it's a
transposed times the diagonal matrix
with B on the diagonal inverted um time
C uh and the trick here is that this is
actually something that can be done in a
single pass over the vectors um but you
have to be able to recognize that so
armadillo can through templates uh G
octave actually can uh but the other
three libraries that I tried they don't
recognize it and so you can't scale like
they're trying to form uh that Matrix
with B on the diagonal and then directly
invert it which doesn't work once you
get to a size of be that's you know like
larger than Ram which is about 100K
right but you can just keep going with
armadillo and octave uh armadillo ends
up being 2 and a half times faster or
something like that um because of the
lack of additional o that you have uh in
C++ okay so that's the speed um there
are two more points I kind of hope to
convince you about uh in the rest of
this talk number one um it's not ugly C+
bus really isn't ugly you know ignore
the millions of er messages um or don't
write uh no um but really it isn't ugly
it's easy to write and read and maintain
I've been doing it for 15 years now uh
and then the second is um the code is
Deployable and that's really the point
of the talk uh you can compile it to be
really small uh you can put it on your
little satellite or your shoe uh and so
this is uh a much more uh pleasing to my
heart image uh of a machine learning
deployment um when you get rid of all
the
CFT so um I'm going to demonstrate all
this through an example and the example
I have picked is language detection U so
I will build a simple language detection
model and then we will see uh what does
C++ get us here so user is going to give
us a string we're going to do some
machine learning and then the user is
going to get back in language that tell
some W language or string ones great
awesome um pretty standard uh what is
actually going on under the hood we're
going to do our three steps of machine
learning from earlier you convert the
the string that you got into some
numbers you put the numbers through some
linear algebra uh and then you turn the
number back into a language and you
print it to the screen um cool uh data
science what are we actually going to do
um I'm actually going to steal a
technique from the malware detection
Community we're going to build a model
directly on the B of the string uh why
am I doing this uh because the model has
to be Slide line has to fit there right
so I don't want to do anything too crazy
so I need to keep it simple um so what
we're going to do is we're going to
count up the number of times we've seen
each individual bite in the string right
so like how many times did 0x1f appear
um you know how many times did that
character appear we'll count them all up
uh but that's not a really great feature
so we'll also compute two GRS or byrs or
like two by sequences uh of these there
will be like 65,000 but that's a lot so
we are going to count in our training
data like 768 the most common of them
and we'll keep those uh those will be
the ones that we care about so that give
us a very nice number 1,24 dimensional
Vector if you smir you could even say
yeah it's in a b um kind of is there a
manual um so that's that's are going to
be our features that we're going to use
the model machine it's a black box we'll
use soft Max regression here you can
plug into something else if you wanted
um and then turning the back into a
language easy
not so I want to show the code um but
the details are not the point uh so I'll
kind of wave my arms around a little bit
um and say look here's a function that
does the thing so here's a function that
does the thing or it actually doesn't do
the thing um this uh it turns out two gs
are not slide compliant it would take me
like two or three slides to put them up
there and what's the point um what I
want to show you here so here's a
function that would compute the the one
GRS or just the bite counts and this
kind of looks like you might expect to
look in another language like with
python you you could use list
comprehensions and things like that make
it a little bit shorter U but like this
is easy enough to read right like uh
create the fill the engrams Matrix with
zeros and then Loop over each string
Loop over each bite in the string add to
the count and then normalize it at the
end great awesome
truly mindblowing here an incredible
complexity um I wrote a class called
engram Lane detect model I probably
shouldn't picked a shorter name but this
is a wide slide so it'll work um it has
kind of three methods of interest that
I'm going to mention one is train one is
classify which you can do either on a
single point or on collection of points
and then one is serialized so we can sa
the model of dis the implementations of
these are are relatively straightforward
um this train function kind of has two
parts uh and the two parts are first you
have to convert the data to numeric data
um and that's you know that's the first
step right so here we we'll use a
compute engrs function um and then uh
our label conversion uh we'll actually
just do do that there it's relatively
this is about what you I'm not going to
go line by line but this is about what
you would end up with if you thought
about it for a minute a road it uh then
the actual training part is relatively
simple mlac provides us a nice blackbox
API here uh and you just call off Max
regression you get a mod awesome
wonderful the classify functions um
these are all three steps of the of the
machine learning pipeline that I talked
about for production and actually it's
even three lines right the first line
turn the string into Data second do
linear algebra to get a number that
represents a class third turn that
number back into a string that
represents language cool awesome a
little bit more a little bit more work
to do that for a bunch of points at once
but you get the idea um the last point
that I I really want to mention in the
implementation here is the serialized
function so in Python uh you can have
things like pickle and python you like
nice Dynamic introspection so pickle can
say excuse me class you want to be
serialized what things do you have in
you um and the class can say I have
these things uh serialize them um that's
not exactly what you get in C++ so in
C++ uh and again this has to do with
like lack of overhead right this is one
of the things that will save us space
that also means on the other hand uh we
have to write the serialized function
manually and we get control over oh we
in the NR Lane detect model class we
have three things to serialize the mlack
model the uh the map of byrams we're
keeping uh and then the names of the
classes themselves uh and here and an ml
pack we use the serial serialization
Library um first because I like it
second because it has a really awesome
logo that's a I I appreciate the logo it
makes me happy so that's like all the
code um the code to train the model
which is not really what we're after uh
but it looks about like you'd expect you
uh you do some loading of all your data
that I've commented out here uh you
create your model you train it uh and
then you you you compute the training
into test accuracies and you print them
to just see does our model make any
sense and then in one line you save
right I'm not changing the world with
these um but compilation is Trivial and
uh so that's quite simple you just call
GCC and uh maybe you want to tell it to
optimize it or whatever you link against
armadillo you get a program so when you
run the program uh which I did on some
data some language detection data that I
found on hugging face uh you get a model
and this model is uh I should also say
um this talk is not about language
detection language detection is like do
not take this model and go home and go
boss man I have found the best possible
language detection model and we are
going to put it in production right now
this is not the way to do it um but it
could be a start right so 96% is
actually not good in the language
detection World um but it's good enough
for us so here's what we actually care
about this is going to be our little
service that's going to actually
classify the language and and it's
really quite simple um you have uh up at
the top you're going to load your model
from whatever the saved model file is uh
and then we're just going to Loop
forever and we're going to read from
standard in um and whenever we get a
line we are going to call classify which
is going to give us a label which we're
going to print and that's what we're
going to do until the user control C's
or control T's or something like that
just to prove it's not slim fa let's
let's see it
work okay so find the right
directory I'll use my statically
compiled version which I'll talk more
about in a minute I'll give it the
model and it starts up instantly right
there's like no no environment to run
right um and and and I'll say let
language detction works better when you
get a longer string so uh hello I am
currently
giving talk at Pi data NYC uh about C++
and it's going extremely well and I am
in the demo
section and it's going to give me the
right result
please hey it did awesome cool hey great
we could even try maybe my German is not
great but it's good enough for that look
it works it's not just SL okay so that's
my demo short demo it did work wonderful
so let's pack this into a container and
so so I took this code and I'm basically
transliterating it into Python and it
kind of looks the same um and so I said
okay I'll do this with scit first and
I'll also do it with pie torch and so
the the pie torch implementation when I
packed that into a pie torch container
it was um 6 and half gigs uh because
pytorch comes with a lot uh when I
packed it into python you know I got the
full package the slim Docker image and
then the outline image it gets down to
what 330 Megs or something like that uh
when I compile in just in the way that I
showed earlier um that C++ program link
it dynamically and throw it into an
outline container I get something that's
around 50 meg um and then you know I can
actually do better than this uh when you
link dynamically so so basically the
thing that our program is linking
against is armadillo which is then
linking against open BL R remember the
the stack that I showed um and if when
we're linking dynamically the entire
Library needs to be there uh so if we're
just doing soft Max progression we are
not using every function that provides
but if it's dynamically linked
everything is there so it's much better
uh if we can just win statically against
open Bloss and tell the compiler uh
please strip out everything that you're
not going to use um so uh here is a
command uh that you can use to compile
um and the way that I came up with this
command the really the important thing
here is just link statically against
open Bloss um and and Link statically
against Li GCC and lip standard C++ uh
you can come up with a command like this
if you go to stack over F and type in
how do I make my C++ program statically
linked small I bet actually chbt could
do an awesome job with that but you end
up with an invocation that works kind of
like this um and also I will point out
the Das compile to optimize
size when you do that and you throw that
into an outline container this gets you
down to about 25 minuts um but we can
even go just a little bit further uh
open boss is actually pretty large uh if
you can link against single threaded
reference Bloss and lay pack you can
save a lck of size um the the drawback
here is that things won't be mul
threaded anymore but if you're deploying
to a really resource constrained device
maybe it doesn't matter um we can also
use the dist less container like I did
uh for the hello world example to save
even more space and when you do this um
just with simple changes there this gets
you down to for mies um so a thing to
highlight here uh when you're talking
about minimum sizes our our hacky little
minimum size of a Python program was
about 50 Megs and then we threw this
language detection model into it and
then increased by like a factor of six
and now it's like 33 Mi um in C++ we
went from about 3 to four Meg that's a
significantly less footprint ad um I
also want to point out uh that this is
really the starting line for size
optimization this this talk is not about
squeezing every bit of size out of
either your python model or out of your
C++ model you could do way better uh so
that statically linked program is only
one and a half Megs so that's what you
know half of your dists container you
could probably make that a lot smaller
if you really dug into it a little bit I
didn't really do that I didn't have time
for the talk and then the model itself
is like
176k um so that's that's getting there
but again this is the starting line not
the Finish Line um
so in conclusion I kind of got a couple
of points that I want you to take home
with you uh the first is you can do data
science in C++ um there's there's more
of an ecosystem than you might think or
might have known um back python
ecosystem is in some ways built on the
C++ ecosystem so you can do data science
directly in C++ that's good um when you
use C++ uh things go fast you don't have
much Flo there's not much over
it uh and third you should be doing data
science deployments in C++ and actually
if you if you were deploying to an iot
uh device or to the edge to npu or
something like this um you really have
to um python is not going to cut it so
you really have to and and I would say
even if you are deploying containers to
the cloud or something like that you
know you might maybe should look into it
right you'll save a
lot
fourth when you compile the C++ those
size Footprints are tribally a lot
smaller than the equivalent Python
program and there's a lot more that you
can get if you dug into it okay so you
can check it out here are the tools that
I use I use ml Pac small and armadillo
and vandit and actually the code for
this is online through it on GitHub so
if you want to rebuild those hello world
Docker containers and Rel the fun um you
you can do that um yeah so I guess I
should I should also say um this is what
I do uh making machine learning code
fast is what I do um I develop open
source software and I do Consulting on
the side to make that happen uh the the
last group that I worked with uh within
the first day I think I had their models
going something like 50 to 80 times
faster um so if this is is the kind of
thing that you need uh well I can tell
you more about the ecosystem and now you
know what I look like um so that's all I
got any
questions yeah um one could you go back
to the last slide for this one yes and
second um what are some tasks that um
are available in Pyon let's say Pyon
conf but not available in C++ and you
absolutely
yeah so the question is what is
available in Python that's not available
in
C++ um and so I have to acknowledge that
was the question right did I get it
right yeah yeah um I have to acknowledge
right there are a lot more python
developers than there are C++ developers
and that in turn means that the python
ecosystem is much larger python is aimed
at prototyping uh and so if you are
trying to work out your data science uh
or you're trying to look at your data or
you're trying to do all of these
exploration tasks um
it's nice to not need to compile your
code every time you do that so like I
mentioned there there is the Zeus cling
interactive notebook I would not call
that anywhere near as mature as what you
might get um in the python environment
there so the the the the quick way I
would answer the question is is by
saying well python great for prototyping
C++ aim more production um but then the
converse is also true you all you can do
production in Python and people do do
that but you pay a price uh you can do
prototyping in C+ plus but you pay a
price yeah go uh how do you VI um how
like C++ fits into natural language
processing ecosystem with hugging face
and all the things that are going on
right now yeah so I I actually don't
know so the question is how does C++ fit
into the natural language processing
ecosystem um I do remember a handful of
years ago using a tool for conditional
random fields that was written C++ um I
don't know
NLP is not my area of expertise so so I
can't actually answer this question very
well um but I would wager a guess that
so so python has done a good job of
figuring out Unicode um and
C++ uh you know there are solutions
there um but there is some complexity
and I think that's a thing that's still
being a little worked out um so I would
say the NLP experience again for
prototyping it's a little bit easier a
lot bit easier potentially uh depending
on what you're doing in Python uh when
you go to prototyping there might be an
additional headache sorry when you go to
production there might be an additional
headache but you can do those things on
a C++ is there any like interoperability
there that you recommend looking into
like taking a text classification model
in Python and then getting it much
faster using C++ yeah so the question is
about interoperability um so as I
mentioned uh tensorflow and pytorch do
have C++ apis uh I have not done this
but it should be relatively
straightforward to say I have my model p
in Python pytorch uh it has these layers
or whatever I'm using it off the shelf
let me just reimplement that in C++ or
you have tools like or something like
this so you can compile down to a
effectively a statically linked program
um so you have that
uh mlac also has python Bindings that
you could use so you could do your
conversion Python and then go okay cool
this is the ml pack python code now I
can directly transliterate this to C++
um there are things like that um and
then if you really want to dig under the
hood um um a decent bit ofit soit for
instance if you train a logistic
regression model init uh depending on
your options that used this lid linear
which is a C library uh you can just dig
into the code and be like how do you
guys call lid linear which is the thing
that I've done and say okay cool let's
let's get rid of the Python part of this
and let me just call Li linear directly
in a c program um that it's not the
easiest thing because Li linear doesn't
have the easiest API you have a dig a
bit but that is another possible thing
that you could
do
I enjoy the talk I think it's a great
talk you got a really great message but
I think you're also misleading people as
why folks don't use
C++ right so I totally agree with you
it's faster in run time it's smaller and
great
ecosystem but for the noice program
which most data scientists fall into the
overhead of getting started is is much
higher than p and when you're in AIG
environment where you have to move fast
most people don't have time to learn the
C++ um I'm just
curious like where C++ is going to help
data scientists who don't they don't
know what to compile most people I would
guess at this conference have no idea
what a Linker is right and so even to
understand the tool chain C++ requires
almost a CS Dee and so I'm I'm curious
what the C++ world is doing to help the
data scientists learn these tools to
make them easier yeah and um I'm on
board with you here uh right like C++ is
not the easiest language and I I
wouldn't claim that uh I I'm essentially
claiming that at the you know so so
let's say you are a beginning data
scientist I'm not going to say it would
be unreasonable for me to say uh hey why
don't you instead of thinking about
python think about C++ no that's not
what I'm saying what I'm saying is you
have done your prototyping uh and it's
time to pass this off to someone who's
going to put this model intruction maybe
this is your data scientist doing this
in some cases it is maybe it's an ml
engineer uh maybe it's just uh a devops
person who has no idea about machine
learning but they say okay well this is
your python code and I need to do
something with it that's really what the
aim is here and so your your other part
of your question was what is the C++
Community doing about this
um I don't have a great answer for that
that's not really
what I from what I have seen that's not
like I don't want to say the words I'm
going to say them in the process of
saying that I don't want to say them I
don't want to say the words that C++ is
not for beginners and and that that's
the the goal that I don't think that's
the goal of the language but it is true
that if you're going to write lower
level code it certainly helps to know a
good bit more about what is going on
under the hood so the you know the the
Cs knowledge the like how does a
processor work um because you need to
understand pointers what you're doing um
that really does come in very useful so
um no I I I agree with you and I I hope
I've said something that elaborates on
that well I I just point out like python
came from an education point of view and
that's why it's easy to use we needed it
to be so anybody could use their
computer and program and so they have
spent 20 plus years focusing on
education of of people who don't really
want to understand thing about so I
think that there is a gap there you know
C++ could come and and help fix but I
don't know that the community is really
interested yeah no and I I I don't see
um from the the C++ folks that I know I
don't see that same kind of emphasis on
ease of use right the emphasis here is
on
uh uh I thought it would be easy to get
to the picture but it back yeah and and
now it's not even worth having gotten to
the picture right cuz that took so much
time it was a big distraction but the
focus is on um low overhead right and on
fast right and so that's a trade-off um
and so C++ specializes that way python
specializes the education way um yeah
it's all trade
Ops I just have a quick question on the
does
theis regression that you did
inlite to that use
elastic as options for it or do you have
to other
classes I think that are we support L2
um at the moment we don't support L1 but
I know how to do it I should implement
it take me a
day uh what do you think about the new
kiden town Mojo it promises to be you
know super saell python is it's kind of
like a ugly python but you know it's
also very young and he has like
comparable performances to compile
language you see a future in those type
of effort of Like You Learn Python and
some other bits but it's still python
your old tool chain is the same as
Python and then you get the same
performance as a native language do you
see that as a valuable direction of
research for people I definitely see it
as valuable but I don't want to throw
shade here Julia was created with the
same idea and I just worked for four
years for a company that was trying to
make a production database in Julia and
it was problematic I think Julia may
eventually get there going and I think
Julia like I there's a part of me that
that hopes to say in 10 years I will not
be up here talking about C++ anymore um
I will be talking about how you can get
all the stuff in Mojo and have all of
the the good things that we were talking
about or maybe in Julia um but uh I'm
holding my tongue because these efforts
take a lot of time um and I haven't seen
it done yet maybe maybe Chris L can I'm
hopeful so um in order to implement what
you're talking about let's say you know
we want to do that so somebody a data
scientist would create a python C
prototype and somebody needs to
translate that into C++ yes is that what
we're talking about essentially is okay
and um and and for everything right all
models everything um that comes in Pon
or whatever it it depends on what what
is available in the ecosystem that you
want to use right so like if you say I
want I'm using random forest in P you do
not need to sit down you could right but
you don't need to sit down and see and
C++ and say let me Implement random
forest from scratch right like there are
libraries that provide that that's why I
talked about the the ecosystem so um you
do need to transliterate um what you're
doing in Python to C++ and maybe change
out the libraries that you're using or
like I said switch to the P towards C++
API um but I mean you're not going to
need to implement machine raring
algorithms by hand right unless that's
the thing you want to do
is there an easy way to figure out um
you know whether something is available
in C+
plus I mean the thought comes into my
head about the discoverability is like
well you ask chat GPT I actually uh
recently I was like what happens if CH
if I ask chat TP to write me an mopack
program and it was like um 95%
approximately wri uh I probably could
have also asked about what other tools
are available I find chat CPT to be a
great like replacement for search engine
I I I know the string I want to pull on
um so I'm just going to write something
like that and see what comes up and then
all of those different strings that I
get back I can go pull on those harder
but I may not be the most talented
person that
searching talk one more
question oh yeah absolutely if you are
working in C or C++ right like these two
it is not exact accurate to say that c
is a subset of C++ but for all
intensitive purposes it is and if you're
writing C++ you have access to C system
calls right so this is what you might be
doing if you if you are say deploying a
machine learning model to a little
embedded device or something uh where
you're getting data from sensors you're
going to use system calls to get the
data from the sensors or something like
that do your machine learning C++ but
those those CIS calls are are C calls
you could even you know this goes even
further you could directly call open
loss you don't need to use a high L high
level linear Library you could directly
call for TR so you're operating at a low
level those things are available to
you so let's thank our
speaker